[Music]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday December
18th and this is what the most discussed
page of YouTube looks like nerdfighter
nerdfighter nerdfighter nerdfighter
nerdfighter nerdfighter nerdfighter Mike
Huckabee Hank it's question Tuesday the
day that I answer real questions from
real nerdfighters but before I do that I
need to answer some questions related to
the secret project what do you think of
a secret project there was a moment
yesterday in the middle of watching
hundreds of videos and talking about
them with thousands of nerdfighters
where I thought that other than my
wedding day this was the happiest I'd
been since I was like seven I mean the
last thing that made me this happy was
probably Fraggle Rock it's just so
amazing to see all these people come
together to support each other and all
these worthy organizations thank you
thank you thank you and watch the videos
find charities you like and support them
is there going to be a punishment before
the end of the year
yes Hank actually communicated with me
in the comments of meltus video
yesterday and so now we get to punish
Hank
Merry Christmas me nerdfighters we don't
have much time so I need you to suggest
punishments and lots of them in the
comments Hank it's gonna hurt so bad
you know how creative the nerdfighters
are now into the rest of question
Tuesday if a nerdfighter falls in the
forest and there's no one there to hear
her fall is she still made of Awesome
that's an excellent question and very
possible because everyone knows that one
nerdfighters are clumsy and two we do
spend a lot of time alone the answer is
the nerdfighters are made out of even
more awesome when they act nerdfighter
Lee when no one is watching what's your
favorite type of muffin blueberry what's
the meaning of life other people what
unit is also measured in is it kill of
sweets or Killa cools I think there's
too much awesome for it to be killing
anything I think it has to be Giga cools
Ralf and Wayne can each cut down five
trees in two hours if they work together
how fast is each person cut down trees
if Ralph takes 20 minutes longer per
tree than Wayne Ralph takes an hour
Wayne takes 40 minutes hey is this
eighth grade mathematics yeah I know I
just have a little bit of news for you
you've been poned what single book
benefits most from having in your pants
added to the title I believe that would
be the Flannery O'Connor classic
everything that rises must converge in
your pants will you please shave sure do
authors really put as much symbolism
into their books as English teachers
seem to think you guys do yes we really
do I promise but the thing is even if we
didn't it wouldn't really matter because
the reading experience would be equally
rich with or without authorial intent
what I'm saying is that if
thousand monkeys writing at ten thousand
typewriters happen to type out Hamlet
Hamlet would still be a really good play
and a really rewarding thing to spend
your time with should I buy your books
is the kind of question that's sure to
get you featured on question Tuesday and
yes is your book Looking for Alaska
based on real-life experience yes and no
what is the book you most wish you'd
written Huck Finn who the eff is Hank
Hank is a small island in the Pacific
Ocean first colonized by the Spanish in
1521 Hank is today known primarily for
his beautiful coral reefs and large
American military presence do you
believe in the paranormal I'll tell you
one thing I don't believe in the normal
if a monkey with a lightsaber battle the
Lemur with a lightsaber who would get
pwned frankly I find it very difficult
to imagine a situation in which either
the Lemur
or the monkey emerges from that battle
unscathed I mean you have to remember
that monkeys and lemurs don't know what
lightsabers do they don't know how they
function and they don't know what
happens to you if you get in the way of
its light beam honestly what your
question makes me think is that we need
to get to work on monkey proofing our
lightsabers if you and Hank found
yourselves trapped in a 2 meter by 2
meter white room with no food or drink
who would get eaten first I have a
couple questions about your question the
first is are you implying that someone
would get eaten second furthermore a 2
meter by 2 meter room only has two
dimensions and that means that we would
only have two dimensions now I'm not an
expert in two-dimensional people but my
suspicion is that they don't need food
or drink in order to survive so no one
would have to eat anybody if you had a
medieval battle cry what would it be
nerdfighters tonight we dine in front of
the TV while watching Battlestar
Galactica but tomorrow we dine on pizza
while discussing Hanks punishment in the
comments section Hank I want to say
thanks again to everyone who
participated in the project nerdfighters
for the win and I'll see you tomorrow
scavenger hunters my dad has your clue